This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Edwin Arlington Robinson published his first book of poems in the late 19th century, a critic decried the poems for their bleak outlook, for painting the world as a prison house. The poet responded, the world is not a prison house, but a kind of spiritual kindergarten, where millions of bewildered infants are trying to spell God with the wrong blocks. In time, Edwin Arlington Robinson would go on to win the first Pulitzer Prize in poetry. In one poem that would later be celebrated in song by Paul Simon and Art Garfunkel, he tells the story of a man named Richard Corey who had every advantage in life.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。19世纪末，埃德温·阿灵顿·罗宾逊出版了他的第一本诗集，一位评论家谴责这些诗作基调阴郁，将世界描绘成一座监狱。诗人回应道，世界并非监狱，而是一种精神幼儿园，数百万困惑的婴儿正试图用错误的积木拼出“上帝”这个词。后来，埃德温·阿灵顿·罗宾逊获得了普利策诗歌奖。在他的一首诗中，这首诗后来被保罗·西蒙和阿特·加芬克尔改编成歌曲，他讲述了一个名叫理查德·科里的男人的故事，他拥有生活中所有的优势。
He tells the story of a man named Richard Quarry, who had every advantage in life. The poem, told from the perspective of people who admired and envied Richard Quarry, goes like this. And he was rich, yes, richer than a king, and admirably schooled in every grace. In fine, we thought that he was everything, to make us wish that we were in his place. But things were not as they seemed. Beneath Richard Corey's success lay a hollow emptiness. The poem ends this way. So on we worked and waited for the light and went without the meat and cursed the bread.
他讲述了一个名叫理查德·科里的男人的故事，他拥有生活中所有的优势。这首诗从那些钦佩并嫉妒理查德·科里的人的角度出发，内容如下：他很富有，是的，比国王还富有，并且在各种优雅礼仪上受过令人钦佩的教育。总之，我们认为他拥有一切，让我们希望自己能处在他的位置。但事实并非如此。在理查德·科里的成功之下，隐藏着一种空虚。诗的结尾是这样的：于是我们继续工作，等待光明，没有肉吃，抱怨面包。
And Richard Corey, one calm summer night, went home and put a bullet through his head. Today on the show we explore the puzzling phenomenon of people who have all the ingredients to live a happy life, yet find themselves drifting through it, empty, invisible, themselves drifting through it. Empty, invisible, directionless. Philosophers may call this an existential dilemma. People of a certain age might describe it as a midlife crisis. Young people may say they feel a drift. What goes on in our minds when we feel this way?
在一个平静的夏夜，理查德·科里回到家，朝自己的脑袋开了一枪。今天在节目中，我们将探讨一个令人困惑的现象：那些拥有幸福生活所需一切要素的人，却发现自己漂泊其中，感到空虚、隐形、漫无目的。哲学家可能称之为存在主义困境。特定年龄的人可能会将其描述为中年危机。年轻人可能会说他们感到漂泊。当我们有这种感觉时，我们的内心发生了什么？
And what is the remedy for these feelings? The science and solutions for emptiness. This week on Hidden Brain. What does it mean to live a good life? For some, it might mean traveling the world, or starting a family, or finding that dream job. We all have different interests, but ultimately we want the same things. To live a life that feels rich, fulfilling, and joyful. The sociologist Corey Keys has studied how people find satisfaction in their lives.
这些感觉的补救措施是什么？关于空虚的科学与解决方案。本周《隐藏的大脑》。过上好生活意味着什么？对一些人来说，这可能意味着环游世界、组建家庭或找到梦想的工作。我们都有不同的兴趣，但最终我们想要的东西是一样的。过上一种感觉充实、满足和快乐的生活。社会学家科里·基斯研究了人们如何在生活中找到满足感。
Over many years of research at Emory University, he has explored why the feeling of well-being doesn't come easy, even when it seems like it should. Corey Keys, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Corey, you have a friend named Denise. She became a new mother and she really wanted to become a mom, but she started to have troubling feelings. Can you describe them for me?
在埃默里大学多年的研究中，他探索了为什么幸福感并不容易获得，即使在看起来应该很容易的时候。科里·基斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。科里，你有一位名叫丹妮丝的朋友。她刚成为新妈妈，她非常渴望成为母亲，但她开始产生令人不安的感觉。你能为我描述一下吗？
Well, she and her husband decided to move from Austin to a suburb outside of Austin in what they call the Hill Country there in Texas. And so she began to feel a bit overwhelmed. And that I got the sense from Denise that this new motherhood stage of her life wasn't everything it was built up to be. This was a planned pregnancy and birth and this child was welcomed into the world. It was wanted and despite all of that, Denise still felt a loss. So Denise talked to a doctor and I suppose wanted to explore whether she was suffering from postpartum depression. Was she? No. They gave her a psychiatric questionnaire and she did not fit the criteria for depression. And I
嗯，她和丈夫决定从奥斯汀搬到奥斯汀郊外的一个地方，也就是他们所说的德克萨斯州希尔乡村。于是她开始感到有些不知所措。我从丹妮丝那里感觉到，她生活中的这个新母亲阶段并不像人们所说的那样美好。这是一次计划内的怀孕和分娩，这个孩子是被欢迎来到这个世界的。它是被期待的，尽管如此，丹妮丝仍然感到一种失落。所以丹妮丝咨询了一位医生，我想她是想探讨自己是否患有产后抑郁症。她是吗？不。他们给了她一份精神病学问卷，她并不符合抑郁症的标准。而我
think she felt a bit of betrayal may not be too strong of a word because she had a sense that something was wrong. And I think what was happening was that she was experiencing what I call a postpartum emptiness. A sense that life isn't quite the way I want it to be or expected it to be. I get this sense that there is some external pressure, if not some internal stereotypes that mothers and fathers bring to the table when they're having children. And that is, they're expected to feel overwhelming joy, and that joy is somehow so supposed to endure and that I don't think it leads them to be prepared for the challenges and even
想她感到了一种背叛，用这个词可能并不算太严重，因为她感觉到有什么地方不对劲。我想发生的事情是，她正在经历我所说的“产后空虚”。一种感觉，即生活并不完全是我想要的或预期的那样。我感觉到有一种外部压力，如果不是内部刻板印象的话，母亲和父亲在生孩子时会带来这些压力。那就是，他们被期望感受到压倒性的快乐，而且这种快乐不知何故应该持续下去，我不认为这能让他们为挑战做好准备，甚至
sometimes what I think is momentous changes that take them away from the their old life that was giving them meaning. I don't think she was experiencing depression but I think she was experiencing depression, but I think it was this sense of loss and emptiness and even feeling a little stagnant as like, and stuck like what to do next, because she was being orchestrated by a very demanding infant.
有时我认为是重大的变化，将他们从赋予他们意义的旧生活中带走。我不认为她患有抑郁症，但我认为这是一种失落和空虚的感觉，甚至感到有点停滞不前，像被困住了一样，不知道下一步该做什么，因为她被一个要求极高的婴儿所支配。
You have another friend Jonas who also experienced this feeling of being adrift. Tell me his story. Yes, Jonas, I love him. When I was writing the book, he was in his 80s and so I had a chance to talk to him, what it was like to be living past what is his life expectancy and doing quite well. Because in his first decade of retirement, roughly 65 to 75, he was active, bubbling, engaged in the world. But then came the 80s and all of a sudden I noticed something shift in Jonas. He began to retreat, and it was a very subtle shift that began to
你还有另一位朋友乔纳斯，他也经历了这种漂泊感。讲讲他的故事吧。是的，乔纳斯，我很爱他。我在写这本书时，他已经80多岁了，所以我有机会和他交谈，了解活过预期寿命并且过得还不错是什么感觉。因为在他退休后的第一个十年，大约65岁到75岁，他很活跃，充满活力，参与世界。但到了80多岁，我突然注意到乔纳斯身上发生了一些变化。他开始退缩，这是一种非常微妙的变化，开始
creep into his life. And all of a sudden when I asked him, he had this rather, I found it startling statement. He told me that he had begun to think that his life was over and that living any longer would not be a gift, but in fact, he used the word curse because he sensed he had nothing left to give to the world. He wasn't being challenged or he didn't have a sense of growth anymore.
潜入他的生活。突然间，当我问他时，他说了这句让我感到震惊的话。他告诉我，他开始认为自己的人生已经结束了，再活下去不再是一份礼物，事实上，他用了“诅咒”这个词，因为他觉得他再也没有什么可以给这个世界了。他不再受到挑战，或者他不再有成长的感觉。
And that's a very, very important warning sign that somebody is beginning to give up on life. What I find striking both about Denise's story and Jonas's story is that both these people have so much to be happy about, so much to be grateful for. Neither of them was suffering from any major trauma or major setback, and it must have felt puzzling to them. You know, things are generally going pretty well. I ought to feel lucky. I ought to feel grateful. And yet I don't. I know. In Jonas' case, we might be quick to judge.
这是一个非常、非常重要的警告信号，表明某人开始放弃生活。关于丹妮丝和乔纳斯的故事，我感到震惊的是，这两个人都有很多值得快乐、值得感恩的地方。他们都没有遭受任何重大的创伤或挫折，这一定让他们感到困惑。你知道，事情总体上进展得相当顺利。我应该感到幸运。我应该感到感激。然而我却没有。我知道。在乔纳斯的案例中，我们可能会很快下结论。
In fact, he's still alive. He still has another day to engage with folks and look out the window and enjoy nature, or actually go out and take a walk and sip some coffee, right, all those simple pleasures. And yet, I wouldn't describe him as ungrateful, but I think what happens is that there is this disconnection between a life that was engaged and had purpose, had belonging and growth, and suddenly a shift to what feels like a
事实上，他还活着。他还有新的一天可以与人交流，望向窗外，享受大自然，或者出去散散步，喝杯咖啡，对吧，所有那些简单的快乐。然而，我不会形容他是不知感恩的，但我认为发生的事情是，一种曾经参与其中、拥有目标、归属感和成长的生活，与突然转变为一种感觉上
fundamentally different way of being in the world, almost a different life. And in between those two different seeming lives is this sense of loss. And that gap, that empty gap, I think is a challenge for anybody no matter how good they have it. Something very similar happened to Corey himself years earlier. He was in graduate school working on his dissertation. He was thrilled to be honing his craft as a thinker and researcher.
根本不同的存在方式之间存在脱节，几乎是另一种生活。在这两种看似不同的生活之间，是一种失落感。我认为，无论一个人拥有多么好的条件，那个空洞的缺口对任何人来说都是一种挑战。科里本人多年前也发生了非常相似的事情。他在读研究生，正在写论文。他很高兴能磨练自己作为思想家和研究者的技能。
But even as he was doing something he deeply loved, even as he was widely exceeding the expectations of a first-generation college student and a first-generation graduate student, he would look up some days and know that something was seriously off. I asked him what these moments of epiphany felt like. Well, I was not living what I was studying. And in particular, my dissertation was about a particular form of well-being called social well-being. And so there I was talking about social integration, social contribution, connection and belonging. And I felt adrift and disconnected and lost, almost
但即使在他做着自己深爱的事情时，即使他远远超出了第一代大学生和第一代研究生的期望，他有时也会抬头看，知道有些事情严重不对劲。我问他这些顿悟时刻是什么感觉。嗯，我并没有活出我所研究的内容。特别是，我的论文是关于一种被称为“社会幸福感”的幸福形式。所以我在那里谈论社会融合、社会贡献、联系和归属感。但我感到漂泊、脱节和迷失，几乎
lost. And I did not feel mentally, emotionally well. And it was such a jarring moment. I said, how can I tell others to do what I think I want them to do given my research when I don't actually live it myself. So after a year or so, your wife began to notice you weren't yourself. What did she suggest to you? She said I should go see a doctor. And this was another jarring moment that I remembered throughout my lifetime and career
迷失了。我感觉在心理和情感上都不健康。那是一个非常刺耳的时刻。我说，既然我自己都没有活出来，我怎么能根据我的研究告诉别人去做我想让他们做的事呢。所以一年左右后，你的妻子开始注意到你不对劲。她向你建议了什么？她说我应该去看医生。这是我一生和职业生涯中记住的另一个刺耳的时刻。
the doctor used the typical, you know, he measured my Anxiety levels and he measured my depression levels and I didn't meet the criteria for any anxiety disorders or any mood disorders So he said Cory you're fine There is nothing wrong with you. Here's my recommendation. And this literally what he said, go home, make yourself a cup of tea and sit down and talk to your wife. That's the best medicine I can recommend.
医生用了典型的，你知道，他测量了我的焦虑水平，测量了我的抑郁水平，我不符合任何焦虑症或情绪障碍的标准。所以他说，科里，你很好。你没有任何问题。这是我的建议。这真的是他所说的，回家，给自己泡杯茶，坐下来和你妻子聊聊。这是我能推荐的最好的药。
Now I didn't take that very well. I didn't say anything to him, but I left there pissed off. I was perturbed. The way he said it wasn't to say, but I left there pissed off. I was perturbed. The way he said it wasn't to say, you know, go connect with your wife. I had a good relationship with my wife. That wasn't the problem. So I felt unseen. I felt invisible after that medical encounter where everything was fine if you're not mentally
我当时并没有很好地接受这一点。我没有对他说什么，但我离开时很生气。我很不安。他说话的方式并不是说，但我离开时很生气。我很不安。他说话的方式并不是说，你知道，去和你妻子建立联系。我和我妻子的关系很好。那不是问题所在。所以在那次医疗接触后，我感到未被看见。我感到隐形，如果一个人没有精神
ill. When we come back, an explanation for the feelings of emptiness many of us experience, even when our lives give us little justification for such emotions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all know what it feels like to be very sad. Most of us recognize that depression is a serious problem, and many of us seek treatment for it. We also know what it feels like to be joyful and happy. But the sociologist Corey Keys says lots of us
疾病，一切就都很好。回来后，我们将解释许多人经历的空虚感，即使我们的生活几乎没有理由产生这种情绪。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都知道非常悲伤是什么感觉。我们大多数人都认识到抑郁症是一个严重的问题，许多人寻求治疗。我们也知道快乐和幸福是什么感觉。但社会学家科里·基斯说，我们很多人
live in an emotional netherworld that falls between these two poles. We are not depressed, but still feel unfulfilled. Corey once heard a woman on TV who was reaching out to Oprah Winfrey. Here's what she said. but still feel unfulfilled. Corey once heard a woman on TV who was reaching out to Oprah Winfrey. Here's what she said. Dear Oprah, I'm a happily married woman
生活在一个介于这两个极端之间的情感阴间。我们没有抑郁，但仍然感到不满足。科里曾经在电视上听到一位女士向奥普拉·温弗瑞求助。她是这样说的。但仍然感到不满足。科里曾经在电视上听到一位女士向奥普拉·温弗瑞求助。她是这样说的。亲爱的奥普拉，我是一位幸福的已婚女性
and a mother of two children. I've been blessed with my health and my financial stability. I'm looking for ways to satisfy an unsettling feeling. It's like a void in the center of my soul. Corey, you say that what this woman is describing, this feeling of a void in the center of her soul, this feeling is far more common than many of us realize? Yes. In fact, I was surprised by the number of people who fit the criteria for what I came
和两个孩子的母亲。我有幸拥有健康和经济稳定。我正在寻找方法来满足一种不安的感觉。就像我灵魂深处的一个空洞。科里，你说这位女士所描述的，这种灵魂深处空洞的感觉，这种感觉比我们许多人意识到的要普遍得多？是的。事实上，我对那些符合我称之为
to call languishing. Languishing is that unsettling feeling, that void that we feel in our soul that she describes about. And as I was listening to that clip, my eyes began to tear up because I remember watching that clip so many years ago and feeling like I identified with what she was going through because I've been there myself.
“萎靡”（languishing）标准的人数感到惊讶。萎靡就是那种不安的感觉，那种她所描述的我们灵魂中感受到的空洞。当我听那段视频时，我的眼泪开始流下来，因为我记得多年前看过那段视频，感觉我认同她所经历的事情，因为我自己也经历过。
You know, when we hear things like this, we sometimes think, you know, maybe this person doesn't really want the things she says she wants. Maybe she's unhappy in her marriage. Maybe she doesn't really want children. But what you're saying is it's actually more complicated than that. We might actually want those things very much, but still feel adrift. Yes, I think it's tempting to look at somebody's life like hers, who has everything that you might expect and maybe more for a good life.
你知道，当我们听到这样的事情时，我们有时会想，你知道，也许这个人并不真正想要她说她想要的东西。也许她在婚姻中不快乐。也许她并不真正想要孩子。但你所说的是，这实际上比那更复杂。我们可能确实非常想要那些东西，但仍然感到漂泊。是的，我认为看着像她这样的人的生活，拥有你可能期望的一切，甚至更多，过上好生活，是很诱人的。
But those are often what we would call in the business external features of life. And even though people may want them, they may think they want them because they may think that brings their life meaning, purpose, and even joy and happiness. When you suddenly have them, you realize sometimes that they're not the solution to all the questions you had
但这些通常是我们在这个行业中所说的生活的“外部特征”。即使人们可能想要它们，他们可能认为他们想要它们，因为他们可能认为这会给他们的生活带来意义、目标，甚至快乐和幸福。当你突然拥有它们时，你有时会意识到它们并不是你所拥有的所有问题的解决方案
about what will create a good life. And so rather than dismiss somebody as saying, well, they're either being disingenuous, even lying to us, I would take the attitude of exploring it deeper because I think people languish not just because they have the deficit of those good things in life, sometimes because they have all the accoutrements that we think make up for a good life, and yet they find that that's a false promise. I want to raise one other issue, which is I think sometimes when we hear stories like this,
关于什么能创造好生活。所以，与其把某人打发走，说他们要么是在虚伪，甚至是在对我们撒谎，我宁愿采取更深入探索的态度，因为我认为人们萎靡不振，不仅是因为他们缺乏生活中那些美好的东西，有时是因为他们拥有我们认为构成好生活的所有装备，然而他们发现那是一个虚假的承诺。我想提出另一个问题，我认为有时当我们听到这样的故事时，
we say, you know, this person is being self-indulgent. You know, they have everything. They have a happy marriage. They have a wonderful family. They have their health. They have their financial stability. How dare they feel unhappy or how dare they tell us they feel adrift? There's a sense that people might be self-entitled.
我们说，你知道，这个人是在自我放纵。你知道，他们拥有一切。他们有幸福的婚姻。他们有美好的家庭。他们有健康。他们有经济稳定。他们怎么敢感到不快乐，或者他们怎么敢告诉我们他们感到漂泊？有一种感觉是人们可能太自我中心了。
And I think this might keep people from actually expressing the fact that they feel empty. I agree wholeheartedly and I think we're often too quick to judgment and I think it's a dangerous thing. The risks that come along with this emptiness, this condition of languishing, if it persists too long. Even a person like we just heard describe the external features of a good life, but yet she has this unsettling feeling of void, those people often fall off the proverbial cliff and become seriously mentally ill, if not suicidal. And so to call it privileged isn't to acknowledge the suffering that comes with this condition, whether you have all the external means or whether you don't.
我认为这可能会阻止人们真正表达他们感到空虚的事实。我完全同意，我认为我们往往太快下判断，我认为这是一件危险的事情。如果这种空虚，这种萎靡的状态持续太久，随之而来的风险。即使是一个像我们刚才听到的那样描述好生活外部特征的人，但她却有这种不安的空洞感，这些人往往会掉下众所周知的悬崖，变得严重精神疾病，甚至自杀。所以称之为特权并不是承认这种状况带来的痛苦，无论你是否拥有所有的外部手段。
And it's a serious risk factor for a lot of problems. How have you come to define this term languishing, Corey? How would you define it? I think the best way to make sense of it is to begin, if we can, with how I diagnose flourishing or what I call mental health. To be mentally healthy, you have to have at least one of the three signs of what I call emotional wellbeing that is either happy, satisfied,
这对很多问题来说是一个严重的风险因素。科里，你是如何定义“萎靡”这个词的？你会如何定义它？我认为理解它的最好方法是，如果可以的话，从我如何诊断“繁荣”（flourishing）或我所说的心理健康开始。要心理健康，你必须至少具备我所说的情感幸福感的三个标志之一，即快乐、满足，
or interested in life every day or almost every day, that you had warm, trusting personal relationships. You may have liked most parts of your personality. We call that self-acceptance. In addition to that, you may feel a sense of belonging or integration to a community. The things you do on a daily basis matter or contribute things of worth and value to people or your community. Your life has purpose, meaning it has direction, or you might feel a sense of personal growth. That is, you're feeling challenged to become a better person. And so languishing is the absence
或者每天或几乎每天对生活感兴趣，你有温暖、信任的个人关系。你可能喜欢你个性的绝大部分。我们称之为自我接纳。除此之外，你可能感到一种归属感或融入社区的感觉。你每天所做的事情很重要，或者为人们或你的社区贡献了有价值的东西。你的生活有目标，意味着它有方向，或者你可能感到一种个人成长。也就是说，你感到被挑战去成为一个更好的人。所以萎靡是
of some very important things that make our life meaningful and worthwhile and the absence of feeling good about a life where you can function well. You have a friend Andrea who gave you a powerful metaphor for this feeling. What did she tell you, Corey? We were sitting out there in a park and she said, well did she tell you, Corey? We were sitting out there in a park and she said, well what are you working on? I told her I'm
一些使我们的生活有意义和值得的非常重要的事情的缺失，以及对一种你可以很好地发挥作用的生活感觉良好的缺失。你有一位朋友安德里亚，她给了你一个关于这种感觉的强有力的隐喻。她告诉你什么，科里？我们当时坐在公园里，她说，嗯，她告诉你什么，科里？我们当时坐在公园里，她说，嗯，你在忙什么？我告诉她我
working on this book of languishing and she said, is it something like this? Imagine yourself on a flight and you're going somewhere and you're almost there but suddenly you can't land and you spend hours and days and months just circling. You start to feel like you're never going to get to where you want to be and you can't go back to where you started. So you start to feel stuck, loss of control. There's no use of feeling mad because it won't solve any problem. So you don't feel anything negative,
正在写这本关于萎靡的书，她说，是这样的吗？想象一下你在飞机上，你要去某个地方，你快到了，但突然你无法降落，你花了几个小时、几天、几个月的时间只是在盘旋。你开始觉得你永远不会到达你想去的地方，你也无法回到你开始的地方。所以你开始感到被困住，失去控制。感到愤怒是没有用的，因为它解决不了任何问题。所以你没有感觉到任何负面的东西，
but you sure don't feel anything good. And there's several elements of that metaphor that I like. For one thing, you know, it's not like the plane is crashing. So it's not like you are in terror or you're really afraid for your life. You're sitting in a comfortable seat, your seat belt's on, you're just circling. So it's not like something terrible is happening. And also, you don't have very much control over when the plane lands. You know, you're not the pilot, you're not the air traffic controller. You don't get to decide when the plane lands. You know, you're not the pilot, you're not the air traffic controller.
但你肯定也没有感觉到任何好的东西。那个隐喻中有几个元素我很喜欢。首先，你知道，飞机并没有坠毁。所以你并不是处于恐惧之中，或者你真的在为你的生命担心。你坐在舒适的座位上，系着安全带，你只是在盘旋。所以并不是发生了什么可怕的事情。而且，你对飞机何时降落没有太多的控制权。你知道，你不是飞行员，你不是空中交通管制员。你不能决定飞机何时降落。你知道，你不是飞行员，你不是空中交通管制员。
You don't get to decide when the plane lands. And so all you can do is sort of set and wait. I know it's, I talk about this condition of where you're forced into sort of a condition of being still. And even though that plane is moving, right. You can't move from that plane seat, right? You can't unbuckle and suddenly you move about. In fact, you'll get into trouble.
你不能决定飞机何时降落。所以你所能做的就是坐着等待。我知道，我谈论的是这种被迫处于静止状态的情况。即使那架飞机在移动，对吧。你不能离开那个飞机座位，对吧？你不能解开安全带突然走动。事实上，你会惹上麻烦。
So I mean, you're forced into this stillness and you're just waiting to be where you thought you wanted to be. And that, I think, puts people in a situation of feeling... well, less than human. Because human beings need to feel this sense of agency, or to feel alive. Now, the moment you describe this wonderful metaphor that Andrea gave you, it feels like there are so many references in popular culture that have tried to speak to the same idea. There was a popular song by M. Byhold, Numb Little Bug, which has this wonderful line, like, your body's in the room, but you're not really there.
所以我的意思是，你被迫处于这种静止状态，你只是在等待到达你认为你想去的地方。我认为，这让人们处于一种感觉……嗯，不像人的境地。因为人类需要感受到这种代理感，或者感受到活着。现在，当你描述安德里亚给你的这个美妙的隐喻时，感觉流行文化中有这么多参考资料试图表达同样的想法。有一首M. Byhold的流行歌曲《Numb Little Bug》，里面有这句美妙的歌词，就像，你的身体在房间里，但你并没有真正存在。
And that really captures this feeling of almost being like a ghost. Yeah. A word that people used quite frequently when I talked to them about languishing and is this sense that I am dying inside or that I feel dead inside. That you're half alive, you're kind of receding into the background, you're becoming invisible.
这真的捕捉到了这种几乎像鬼魂一样的感觉。是的。当我与人们谈论萎靡时，人们经常使用的一个词是这种感觉，即我在内心死去，或者我感觉内心已经死了。你半死不活，你正在退回到背景中，你正在变得隐形。
And I think sometimes they mean invisible even to themselves, but especially invisible to other people, because I think what happens when you start to languish is that you start to act like a person who's not really there. When the conditions and circumstances of life take away the person you want to be and begin to replace it with a person you never imagined you could ever become. You know, we might imagine that this afflicts
我认为有时他们的意思是隐形，甚至是对他们自己而言，但特别是对其他人而言，因为我认为当你开始萎靡时，你会开始表现得像一个并不真正存在的人。当生活的条件和环境夺走了你想成为的那个人，并开始用一个你从未想象过自己会成为的人来取代它时。你知道，我们可能会想象这折磨着
ordinary people, but we often imagine, you know, very successful people, people who've reached the top of their game, people who are celebrities, that this doesn't affect them. But I'm reminded of that line from Andre Agassi, the tennis star, and his biography, he says, feeling depressed after a loss is one thing, but feeling depressed about nothing, about life in general, is another thing altogether. And it
普通人，但我们往往想象，你知道，非常成功的人，达到巅峰的人，名人，这不会影响他们。但我记得安德烈·阿加西，那位网球明星，在他的传记中说，输球后感到沮丧是一回事，但对虚无、对一般生活感到沮丧则是另一回事。它
reminds me in some ways that success, external success in itself, is no defense against languishing. No. And in fact, having just said that person you want to be sometimes isn't the person when you arrive that you realized that you really wanted to be. And I think success sometimes isn't everything that it's baked up to be. Andre Agassi, you know, he had a very disciplined father who really worked him through the paces. And I think part of his loss of the joy of success came from having to sacrifice so much in order to become nearly perfect. And I think there's something about it, if I had a chance to talk to my... Is there something about becoming so successful and sacrificing so much for a game that ends up being something you leave behind and isn't really your life afterwards? Sometimes you thought you wanted that, and then you get there and you realize
在某种程度上提醒我，成功，外部成功本身，并不是抵御萎靡的防御。不。事实上，刚才说了你想成为的那个人，有时并不是你到达时意识到你真正想成为的那个人。我认为成功有时并不像人们所说的那样。安德烈·阿加西，你知道，他有一位非常严厉的父亲，真的让他经历了各种磨练。我认为他失去成功快乐的部分原因，来自于为了变得近乎完美而不得不牺牲太多。我认为关于这一点，如果我有机会和我的……有没有关于变得如此成功并为一场最终成为你抛在脑后、之后并不是你真正生活的游戏牺牲太多的事情？有时你以为你想要那个，然后你到了那里，你意识到
this doesn't bring you any more purpose and joy than you thought it would. You say there are crucial differences between languishing and depression. What are some of these differences, Corey? It's true that there's one question that I ask that overlaps with what psychiatrists use to diagnose depression, and that is interest in life. But all of the remaining other eight questions that diagnose clinical depression are the presence and absence of some very negative things, persistent sadness, and
这并没有给你带来比你想象中更多的目标和快乐。你说萎靡和抑郁之间有关键的区别。这些区别是什么，科里？确实，我问的一个问题与精神科医生用来诊断抑郁症的问题有重叠，那就是对生活的兴趣。但诊断临床抑郁症的其余八个问题都是关于一些非常负面的东西的存在和缺失，持续的悲伤，以及
then a whole host of what they call malfunctioning, sleeping too much and sleeping too little, eating too much, eating too little. No longer wanting to live when before you had no reason to think of suicide. Depression is all about the presence or absence of very negative sides. All of the questions for languishing and flourishing are about the presence of good things or the absence of things like purpose, belonging, integration, growth, autonomy. You can be free of those negative signs of depression and yet not be filled with the positive symptoms of flourishing. And that is why I, along with Adam Grant, have described languishing as this middle child.
然后是一大堆他们所谓的“功能失调”，睡得太多和睡得太少，吃得太多，吃得太少。不再想活下去，而之前你没有理由考虑自杀。抑郁症完全是关于非常负面的东西的存在或缺失。所有关于萎靡和繁荣的问题都是关于好东西的存在，或者像目标、归属感、融合、成长、自主权等东西的缺失。你可以没有那些抑郁症的负面迹象，却仍然没有充满繁荣的积极症状。这就是为什么我与亚当·格兰特一起，将萎靡描述为这个“中间的孩子”。
Depression is the presence of negative things only. Languishing is the absence of both the negative and the positive. absence of both the negative and the positive. Corey thinks people are most likely to experience languishing in adolescence and in their early twenties, and again later in life, after they reach retirement age. At the beginning, I think to be a young person is the sense that you're really not needed and there's not much of a purpose for you Right and and you may have this sense of belonging, but you know, it's all temporary Because life is very fluid when you're young and you're moving and you know
抑郁症仅是负面东西的存在。萎靡是负面和正面东西的缺失。负面和正面东西的缺失。科里认为人们最有可能在青春期和二十出头时经历萎靡，然后在生命后期，达到退休年龄后再次经历。起初，我认为作为一个年轻人，感觉是你真的不需要，也没有什么目标。对，而且你可能有这种归属感，但你知道，这都是暂时的，因为当你年轻时，生活是非常流动的，你在移动，你知道
You're going not going to stay here long and you're in this long prolonged stage of becoming an adult In fact, it's taking longer for people to get married and have a full-time career. And they're not even married to the ages of 28 to 30. So there's a prolonged period where they're sort of like, you're not the person you want to be or society expects you to be. And at the end of life, you're not the person society needs or dare I say wants. You have to find your own way. We have no need. And I remember a haunting phrase, a book that I've loved, Sebastian Junger, in his book,
你不会在这里待太久，你处于这种漫长的成年阶段。事实上，人们结婚和拥有全职职业的时间越来越长。他们甚至在28到30岁之前都没有结婚。所以有一个漫长的时期，你有点像，你不是你想成为的人，也不是社会期望你成为的人。而在生命尽头，你不是社会需要或者我敢说想要的人。你必须找到自己的路。我们没有需求。我记得一本我喜欢的书，塞巴斯蒂安·荣格的《部落》，开头有一句令人难忘的话，
Tribe, at the beginning said, the modern world is very hard on people because it tells them they're not necessary. That sense of, you aren't necessary, we don't need you, I found that very haunting. I went back and read the introduction to tribe and it blends well into what we're talking about. At the beginning and the end of life, society says, well, you're not necessary. Hmm. And in some ways, Corey, this points to perhaps, you know, the first factor that leads to languishing. I mean, broadly defined, social isolation or social exclusion is one of the drivers of
《部落》开头说，现代世界对人们非常苛刻，因为它告诉他们，他们是不必要的。那种“你是不必要的，我们不需要你”的感觉，我发现非常令人难忘。我回去读了《部落》的引言，它很好地融入了我们正在谈论的内容。在生命的开始和结束时，社会说，嗯，你是不必要的。嗯。在某种程度上，科里，这或许指出了，你知道，导致萎靡的第一个因素。我的意思是，广义上定义，社会孤立或社会排斥是导致
languishing. Yes. And I found it intriguing that there is this public health recognition and growing awareness of the importance of loneliness. And loneliness is for many people a big part of languishing. There are three questions in my functioning well category that get at whether or not you feel really deeply connected. The first one is that do you have warm, trusting relationships with other people? Second, do you have a sense of belonging to a community? And third, do you do things or have the ability to contribute things to others in your community? We sociologists call that mattering. And when you don't matter,
萎靡的驱动因素之一。是的。我发现有趣的是，公众健康对孤独重要性的认识和意识正在增长。对许多人来说，孤独是萎靡的一大部分。在我的“功能良好”类别中有三个问题，涉及你是否感到真正深刻的联系。第一个是，你是否与他人有温暖、信任的关系？第二个，你是否有归属感？第三个，你是否做事情，或者有能力为社区中的其他人做出贡献？我们社会学家称之为“重要性”（mattering）。当你并不重要，
when you're not needed, and when you don't feel you belong, even though you're part of a community, but you're not welcomed and you don't feel you belong, and when you don't have warm, trusting relationships, that, for me, gets at the heart of pathological loneliness. pathological loneliness. Corey says languishing, like depression, can be a driver of self-harm. There's a study that I review in my book among Hungarian teenagers who are languishing, and the more severely they were languishing, the more likely in the
当你不需要，当你感到不属于这里，即使你是社区的一部分，但你不受欢迎，你没有归属感，当你没有温暖、信任的关系时，对我来说，这触及了病理性孤独的核心。病理性孤独。科里说，萎靡和抑郁一样，可能是自残的驱动因素。我在我的书中回顾了一项关于匈牙利青少年的研究，他们正在萎靡，他们萎靡得越严重，在
past month they were engaged in various forms of non-suicidal self-harm, pinching, pulling hair, cutting, and so forth. And my sense is when you feel nothing or feel empty, it's an undesirable situation that you want to distract yourself from. Or if you're feeling nothing you would rather feel pain than nothing.
过去一个月里，他们参与各种形式的非自杀性自残（捏、拔头发、割伤等）的可能性就越大。我的感觉是，当你什么都感觉不到或感到空虚时，这是一种你想要分散注意力的不理想情况。或者如果你什么都感觉不到，你宁愿感到疼痛也不愿什么都感觉不到。
I want to talk about a paradoxical source of languishing and that might be our perennial search for happiness. You once had a course called the Sociology of Happiness and on the first day of each semester you would give students a very curious assignment. Tell us what you did, Corey. Yeah, their assignment was to go out and spend time finding ways to feel happy. And they giggled and they thought, well, this is the way this course is going to be. finding ways to feel happy. And they giggled and they thought, well, this is the way this course is going to be. This is easy.
我想谈谈萎靡的一个矛盾来源，那可能是我们对幸福的永恒追求。你曾经有一门课叫“幸福社会学”，在每个学期的第一天，你会给学生一个非常奇怪的作业。告诉我们你做了什么，科里。是的，他们的作业是出去花时间寻找让自己感到快乐的方法。他们咯咯地笑，他们想，嗯，这就是这门课的方式。寻找让自己感到快乐的方法。他们咯咯地笑，他们想，嗯，这就是这门课的方式。这很容易。
Oh, and of course they have to write it up, but it was a short, I called them journal assignments. It was no more than three pages. And then I gave them a little prompt, tell me about how you went about feeling happy. And the point I made was find a way to be happy And then I gave them a little prompt, tell me about how you went about feeling happy. And the point I made was, find a way to be happy that endures, that lasts longer at least than an hour.
哦，当然他们必须写下来，但我称之为简短的日记作业。不超过三页。然后我给了他们一个小提示，告诉我你是如何去寻找快乐的。我提出的观点是，找到一种快乐的方法，然后我给了他们一个小提示，告诉我你是如何去寻找快乐的。我提出的观点是，找到一种快乐的方法，
And tell me the longest period that you stayed happy and how you did it. And they go out there. and how you did it. And they go out there. As our framers of the, this country said, well, pursuing happiness. Relentlessly.
这种方法要持久，至少要持续一个小时以上。并告诉我你保持快乐的最长时间以及你是怎么做到的。他们出去了。以及你是怎么做到的。他们出去了。正如我们这个国家的奠基人所说，嗯，追求幸福。无情地。
Endlessly. And they marched off smiles on their face thinking this is going to be the easiest semester ever. And they come back. And almost every journal was, I failed. I failed. And they're like, what's going on here? This sounded like the easiest assignment. They don't understand that emotions were meant to be very time limited. They weren't meant to endure. Emotions are, as I describe in the book,
无休止地。他们脸上带着微笑出发，认为这将是有史以来最简单的学期。然后他们回来了。几乎每一篇日记都是，我失败了。我失败了。他们就像，这里发生了什么？这听起来像是最简单的作业。他们不明白情绪注定是非常有时限的。它们并不注定要持久。情绪是，正如我在书中描述的那样，
they're like that windsock out there on the landing strip that planes come to land. They are moving gently and with every change in the wind, telling us at any moment what is going on and what we might do to adjust or manage in that moment. And then they go away, allowing the next motion, the next so-called breeze to come and blow the windsock. Kory asked his students to think about what it meant to flourish. Was it about having purpose, social connection, or was it merely happiness, feeling good? And here is what happened. The feeling good stuff came in first place. Students put feeling good as far more important for their life than functioning well. And that's where happiness sometimes gets us in trouble. Because if you put happiness first, I think it impedes, if not prevents people from going out and working and doing some hard work of functioning better in life, belonging, contribution, acceptance, growth, autonomy, all those things.
它们就像飞机降落跑道上的那个风向袋。它们轻轻移动，随着风的每一次变化，随时告诉我们发生了什么，以及我们在这个时刻可以做些什么来调整或管理。然后它们就消失了，允许下一个动作，下一个所谓的微风来吹动风向袋。科里让他的学生思考“繁荣”意味着什么。是关于拥有目标、社会联系，还是仅仅是幸福、感觉良好？结果如下。感觉良好的东西排在第一位。学生们把感觉良好看得比功能良好对他们的生活重要得多。这就是幸福有时让我们陷入麻烦的地方。因为如果你把幸福放在第一位，我认为它会阻碍，如果不是阻止人们出去工作并做一些让生活功能更好的艰苦工作，归属感、贡献、接纳、成长、自主权，所有这些事情。
Those take work. They require you to become a better human being and become better for people, not just better than other people. And so I'm echoing something that I learned from Aristotle. He didn't deny that pleasure was the basis of a good life, but what he was really against was putting it first. For Aristotle, putting happiness first would discourage us from working to become excellent at this business of being a human being. Prioritize excellence, that is, functioning well, and you will have something meaningful to be happy about that's far more sustainable. And that's the point I want to make to your question.
那些需要工作。它们要求你成为一个更好的人，并为人们变得更好，而不仅仅是比别人更好。所以我正在呼应我从亚里士多德那里学到的东西。他并不否认快乐是好生活的基础，但他真正反对的是把它放在第一位。对亚里士多德来说，把幸福放在第一位会阻碍我们努力成为一个优秀的人。优先考虑卓越，即功能良好，你就会有一些有意义的事情可以快乐，而且更可持续。这就是我想回答你的问题。
Because people who are functioning well often feel good about a life that's worthy of feeling happy about. But there are students that I've found, upwards of 22%, who are feeling happy and feeling good. But they're not flourishing when it comes to the criteria of functioning well and guess what? They have three times the rate of mental illness than the young
因为功能良好的人通常会对一种值得快乐的生活感到良好。但我发现有学生，高达22%，他们感到快乐，感觉良好。但当涉及到功能良好的标准时，他们并没有繁荣，猜猜怎么着？他们的精神疾病率是那些繁荣的年轻人的三倍。
people who are flourishing. So if feeling good were enough, wouldn't you think they would be no more depressed or anxious than the kids who are flourishing? You would, but they're not. When we come back, how to fight languishing. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. At some point in your life, you might have had a strange feeling. Even when things were going well and you had every reason to be happy, you felt empty and adrift. You might have asked yourself, do I need a new job?
人谁正在繁荣。所以如果感觉良好就足够了，你不认为他们会比那些繁荣的孩子更不抑郁或焦虑吗？你会这么想，但他们不是。回来后，如何对抗萎靡。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在人生的某个时刻，你可能有一种奇怪的感觉。即使事情进展顺利，你有充分的理由感到快乐，你却感到空虚和漂泊。你可能问过自己，我需要一份新工作吗？
Should I leave my spouse? Do I need to have children? Sometimes we find the answer by making radical changes. Often we don't. The sociologist Corey Keys is the author of, Languishing, How to Feel Alive Again in a World that Wears Us Down. He says, a variety of factors shape whether we languish or flourish.
我应该离开我的配偶吗？我需要生孩子吗？有时我们通过做出激进的改变找到答案。通常我们不会。社会学家科里·基斯是《萎靡：如何在让我们疲惫的世界中再次感到活着》的作者。他说，多种因素决定了我们是萎靡还是繁荣。
Corey, we've talked at some length about the role that social connections play in both languishing and in flourishing. Researchers once ran a study looking into the wellbeing of mothers who are looking after children with serious health issues, but some of them had social connections and some of them did not. Tell me about the study and what it found. Yes, this was research that Elissa Epple had done and some of it was with Elizabeth
科里，我们已经详细讨论了社会联系在萎靡和繁荣中所扮演的角色。研究人员曾经进行了一项研究，调查那些照顾有严重健康问题的孩子的母亲的幸福感，但其中一些人有社会联系，而另一些人没有。告诉我这项研究以及它的发现。是的，这是埃丽莎·埃普尔所做的研究，其中一些是与伊丽莎白·布莱克本合作的，他们正在研究那些照顾有严重残疾的孩子的母亲。所以他们正在研究暴露于慢性压力。当然，他们发现的是，照顾的年数越多，意味着暴露于这种慢性压力，意味着暴露于这种慢性压力。
Blackburn and they were studying mothers who were caregivers for a child who had serious disabilities. And so they were studying exposure to chronic stress. And of course, what they found was the more years of caregiving and meaning exposure to this chronic stress, meaning exposure to this chronic stress. And especially that exposure without support from family or friends accelerated telomere damage, which is a measure of aging. So they were aging faster without support. But the mothers who had more support
特别是没有家人或朋友支持的暴露，加速了端粒损伤，这是一种衰老的衡量标准。所以他们在没有支持的情况下衰老得更快。但那些从家人、朋友和其他人那里得到更多支持，但照顾年数更多的母亲，却受到了一点保护，免受损伤。他们发现，作为一名正在经历这种挑战性事情的母亲，暴露在支持性、关怀、充满爱的关系中。暴露在其中似乎激活了一种叫做端粒酶的保护酶，它保护我们端粒的末端免受压力的损伤。这不是一个完美的解决方案。一个完美的解决方案，压力仍然会发生，但它减缓了它。所以，当你经历挑战和逆境时，支持性、关怀的关系，在生物学层面上为我们做了保护免受压力所需的事情。我发现这是一个美丽的
from family, friends, and others, and yet had more years of caregiving, were slightly protected against the damage. And what they found was that being exposed to supportive, caring, loving relationships as a mother who's going through this challenging thing. Being exposed to that seems to activate a protective enzyme called telomerase that protects the ends of our telomeres against the damage of stress. It's not a perfect solution. A perfect solution, the stress still happens, but it slows it down. And so something about supportive, caring relationships, when you're undergoing challenge and adversity, gets under our skin and does for us, at the biological level, what's needed to be protected against stress. I find that a beautiful
来自家人、朋友和其他人的支持，即使在经历了多年的照护工作后，也能在一定程度上抵御伤害。研究发现，作为一名正在经历这种挑战的母亲，接触到支持性、关爱和充满爱的关系，似乎能激活一种名为端粒酶的保护性酶，这种酶能保护我们的端粒末端免受压力损害。这并非完美的解决方案，压力依然存在，但它能减缓损害。因此，当你经历挑战和逆境时，支持性、关爱性的关系会深入我们的内心，在生物学层面为我们提供抵御压力所需的保护。我觉得这非常美好。
beautiful example of just what caring and support does for us. Because it's suggesting of course that it's not the absence of stress that keeps us from languishing but social connection in the face of stress. Indeed. I have a colleague who's a medical doctor who is looking at three forms of medicine that are extremely demanding. These three medical specialties are emergency medicine, general surgery, and obstetrics and gynecology. What she and her colleagues found was that the level of work demands in that,
这是关怀和支持对我们作用的一个绝佳例证。因为它暗示了，当然，让我们免于萎靡不振的不是压力的缺失，而是在压力面前的社会联结。确实如此。我有一位医生同事，她正在研究三种要求极高的医学领域。这三个医学专业分别是急诊医学、普通外科以及妇产科。她和她的同事们发现，在这些领域中，工作需求水平，
nonetheless demanding three specialties, wasn't correlated with whether you were flourishing or languishing. It was whether you were working in a supportive work environment. And if you weren't working in a supportive environment, you're much more likely over time to languish. And here, if you were working in a demanding profession, but had a supportive environment, you could sustain flourishing.
尽管这三个专业要求很高，但与你是否处于蓬勃发展或萎靡不振的状态并无关联。关键在于你是否在一个相互支持的工作环境中工作。如果你没有在支持性的环境中工作，随着时间的推移，你更有可能陷入萎靡。而在这里，如果你从事的是一份高要求的工作，但拥有一个支持性的环境，你就能够维持蓬勃发展的状态。
And here's the four things that make up a supportive environment. You work in a calm, pleasant atmosphere with coworkers. I call that you get along. The second is you have coworkers who understand that you will sometimes have bad days. In other words, we all have bad days. Three, they work with coworkers who are there for them when they need it, and they have those bad days. And last, they had what I call genuine collegiality, meaning they experienced warm, open, and trusting relationships among their colleagues. So it wasn't being exposed to very
以下是构成支持性环境的四个要素。第一，你与同事在平静、愉快的氛围中工作。我称之为“相处融洽”。第二，你的同事理解你有时会有糟糕的日子。换句话说，我们都会有状态不佳的时候。第三，他们与那些在需要时会提供支持的同事一起工作，尤其是在那些糟糕的日子里。最后，他们拥有我所说的“真正的同事友谊”，这意味着他们在同事之间体验到了温暖、开放和信任的关系。所以，这并不是因为暴露在非常
demanding, stressful conditions. It was being exposed to demanding, stressable conditions without a supportive environment that created languishing. One of the components of flourishing that you say is really important is the idea of play. There's been research that's looked at this idea that in some ways, play and playfulness are essential components of flourishing. Talk about this idea, Corey. Yes, and when we typically talk about play
高要求、充满压力的条件下。而是因为在没有支持性环境的情况下暴露在这些高要求、充满压力的条件下，才导致了萎靡不振。你提到的蓬勃发展的组成部分之一，即“游戏”的概念，非常重要。有研究探讨了这一观点，即在某种程度上，游戏和玩乐是蓬勃发展的基本组成部分。谈谈这个想法吧，科里。是的，当我们通常谈论游戏
and studying play, most play researchers focus on children, and for good reason. That's the period where we expect and desire play to happen, but play is still an important ingredient of even in adulthood. I write about the story of the creation
和研究游戏时，大多数游戏研究人员关注的是儿童，这有充分的理由。那是我们期望并渴望游戏发生的时期，但游戏即使在成年期也是一个重要的成分。我写过关于创造的故事
of the pinball machine of all things. And there's a book that was written by someone from my alma mater at University of Wisconsin about a man who saved pinball because the pinball machine was created during the Great Depression. And it was created to help people feel better during a time when almost uniformly,
弹球机的故事。我母校威斯康星大学的一位校友写过一本书，讲述了一个拯救了弹球机的人的故事，因为弹球机是在大萧条时期创造出来的。它的创造是为了帮助人们在那个几乎所有人都在
they felt despair and a lack of hope. Now, why? You would think something that's a game and meant for play was created to create happiness and joy in the midst of misery and hopelessness? Well, the creator, the originator of the game, Pinball, was asked, and there's a wonderful movie I highly recommend it to watch.
感到绝望和缺乏希望的时期感觉好一些。那么，为什么呢？你可能会认为，一个作为游戏且旨在玩乐的东西，是为了在苦难和绝望中创造幸福和快乐而创造的？嗯，游戏的创造者，弹球机的发明者，曾被问及这个问题，有一部很棒的电影，我强烈推荐观看。
What makes a game good? And I was astonished by his answer. He said the following, it provides people with a sense of accomplishment. A really good game makes people happy and helps them flourish because the game requires them to accomplish something. The second is a good game requires the person playing it to develop some skill in order to accomplish those goals so you become aware that you are a source of cause and effect in the world. And last, a good game makes people feel that what they do matters. Hmm.
什么让一个游戏变得好玩？他的回答让我感到震惊。他是这样说的：它为人们提供了一种成就感。一个真正好的游戏能让人快乐，并帮助他们蓬勃发展，因为游戏要求他们完成某件事。其次，一个好的游戏要求玩家为了实现这些目标而发展出一定的技能，这样你就会意识到你是世界上因果关系的源头。最后，一个好的游戏让人们觉得他们所做的事情很重要。嗯。
And there's a larger lesson here, which is the lesson of self-improvement and personal growth. In some ways, when we are experiencing those things, it feels incompatible to feel like we're languishing at the same time that we're growing. Yes. There is something about this sense
这里有一个更大的教训，那就是自我提升和个人成长的教训。在某种程度上，当我们经历这些事情时，感觉自己萎靡不振的同时又在成长，似乎是不相容的。是的。这种感觉确实有些特别
of getting better at something that makes people feel alive. The way I think about it is that sense of growth that comes from learning and developing skill is what we do that's comparable to what plants do by photosynthesizing the sun. It's our form of photosynthesis, and we come to feel like we're alive. I remember coming across the quote, nothing in nature lives for itself. The river doesn't drink its own water.
在某方面变得更好，让人感到充满活力。我的理解是，那种源于学习和发展技能的成长感，就像植物通过光合作用吸收阳光一样。这是我们的一种“光合作用”，我们开始感到自己活着。我记得读过这样一句话：自然界中没有什么是为自己而活的。河流不喝自己的水。
The fruit trees do not eat its own fruit. Only human beings have the choice to live only for themselves. But when we are growing and our heart and our minds are in the right direction, what grows within us we give to others. So, I've always thought of flourishing as the pinnacle of life, because when it seems to me that when people are flourishing, they can't keep it to themselves. It's almost like it's contagious. Flourishing does not always mean that you are happy, Cory says. A life of meaning, purpose, and social connection often involves loss and grief.
果树不吃自己的果实。只有人类有选择只为自己而活的权利。但当我们成长，当我们的心和思想朝着正确的方向前进时，我们在内心成长起来的东西，我们会给予他人。所以，我一直认为蓬勃发展是生命的巅峰，因为在我看来，当人们蓬勃发展时，他们无法将其据为己有。这几乎就像是会传染的。科里说，蓬勃发展并不总是意味着你很快乐。一个充满意义、目标和社交联结的生活往往伴随着失去和悲伤。
When you mourn a beloved dog who has died, you might not be happy, but your grief reminds you that you had a deep connection with another creature. When students tell Corey that they are sad to be graduating, he tells them this. That feeling of sadness is telling you you should also feel happy about what has happened here. You feel sad because you're leaving behind something that mattered to you where you invested some of yourself and you maybe made really meaningful connections and had really positive experiences. And now they're done and you have to move on.
当你哀悼一只死去的爱犬时，你可能并不快乐，但你的悲伤提醒你，你曾与另一个生命有过深刻的联结。当学生告诉科里他们为即将毕业感到难过时，他会这样告诉他们：那种悲伤的感觉是在告诉你，你也应该为你在这里所经历的一切感到高兴。你感到难过是因为你要离开一些对你很重要的地方，在那里你投入了自己的一部分，也许建立了非常有意义的联结，并有了非常积极的体验。现在这一切结束了，你必须继续前进。
And you're going to experience sadness because it's telling you, you should also be happy about what this meant to you. Take it with you. And that's why that sadness is there, even when we lose people who are close to us and they die. And I did this with my grandmother. She lives on with me to this day, even though she died in 1986. me to this day, even though she died in 1986. And I still feel sad that I still can't have her here, but that sadness reminds me of something good that I carry with me from her. So I think there are sometimes sadness and these negative emotions we lean into them, and we should because they're there to teach us
你会经历悲伤，因为它在告诉你，你也应该为你所经历的这一切对你的意义感到高兴。带着它继续前行。这就是为什么那种悲伤会存在，即使当我们失去亲近的人，他们去世时也是如此。我对我祖母就是这样。尽管她在1986年去世了，但她至今仍活在我心中。我仍然为不能让她在这里而感到难过，但那种悲伤提醒我，我从她那里继承了一些美好的东西。所以我认为，有时悲伤和这些负面情绪，我们应该去接纳它们，因为它们的存在是为了教导我们
there are good things that we take from moments that we feel sad about. Languishing and flourishing is not just about us. All of us can help others feel wanted and needed to give them cause to flourish. Corey remembers one difficult time in his own life where he felt he had lost his way and things looked very bleak.
我们从感到悲伤的时刻中获得了一些美好的东西。萎靡和蓬勃发展不仅仅关乎我们自己。我们所有人都可以帮助他人感到被需要和被重视，给他们蓬勃发展的理由。科里回忆起他自己生命中一段艰难的时期，那时他觉得失去了方向，一切看起来都非常黯淡。
The immediate thought that came to mind was, well, I'm no longer needed here. And I lost my sense of purpose. And so that moment became a very dangerous one because I had a purpose and suddenly I felt it was gone. But I was rescued, literally. Shankara, I was rescued because my wife came home early one night and I had thought I would literally come very close to ending my life. And because I was, I really was convinced she didn't need me, the world didn't need me, and I was exhausted having worked so hard to prove my worth and belonging.
脑海中浮现出的第一个念头是：好吧，我在这里不再被需要了。我失去了目标感。所以那一刻变得非常危险，因为我曾经有目标，突然间我觉得它消失了。但我被救了，真的。尚卡拉，我被救了，因为我妻子那天晚上早早回家了，而我当时真的差点就结束了自己的生命。因为我当时真的确信她不需要我，世界也不需要我，我为了证明自己的价值和归属感而努力工作，已经精疲力竭了。
But she came home, found me, and I told her what was going on. I said, I can't do this anymore. I'm just, I've worked so hard and, you know, other people are doing this now that you don't need me. And she said, four words that I'll never forget. But I need you. And that shocked me back into, It brought me back right into life. And I said, oh my God, really? We need to feel alive, not stuck and stagnant
但她回家发现了我的状态，我告诉了她发生了什么。我说，我再也做不下去了。我只是，我工作得太努力了，你知道，现在别人在做这些事，你不需要我了。她说了一句我永远不会忘记的四个字：但我需要你。那句话让我震惊，把我拉回了现实。它把我带回了生活中。我说，天哪，真的吗？我们需要感到活着，而不是被困住和停滞不前
like a pool of water that's trapped. Because there is everything in nature, and we were a part of nature, was planted here to grow. And not only to feel alive, but to beget and generate and give life to other things. Kori Keys is the author of languishing, how to feel alive again in a world that wears us down. Kori, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar. If you're struggling with feelings of languishing, depression, or thoughts of self-harm, please
就像一潭死水。因为自然界中的一切，我们也是自然的一部分，被种植在这里是为了生长。不仅是为了感到活着，更是为了繁衍、创造并赋予其他事物生命。科里·凯斯是《萎靡：在一个让我们疲惫的世界中如何重获活力》一书的作者。科里，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡拉。如果你正在与萎靡、抑郁或自残的想法作斗争，请
reach out to someone who can help. Get in touch with a parent, a friend, or a spiritual advisor. In the United States, you can call or text the Suicide and Crisis Lifeline at 988 to connect with counselors who can offer free confidential and immediate emotional support that number again is 9 8 8 hidden brain is produced by hidden brain media our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul Kristen Wong Laura Quirell Ryan Katz autumn Barnes Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
向能提供帮助的人寻求支持。联系父母、朋友或精神导师。在美国，你可以拨打或发送短信至988自杀与危机生命线，与咨询师取得联系，他们可以提供免费、保密且即时的情感支持。再次重复那个号码是988。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作，我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Katie Gold. She's an audience growth coordinator at SiriusXM, our distribution and ad sales partner. Katie works closely with us on a variety of projects designed to introduce new listeners to Hidden Brain. She's one of those people who make you say, how did we ever survive without this person's help?
我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是凯蒂·戈尔德。她是SiriusXM的受众增长协调员，也是我们的分发和广告销售合作伙伴。凯蒂与我们在各种旨在向新听众介绍《隐藏的大脑》的项目上密切合作。她是那种让你感叹“没有这个人的帮助我们怎么活下去”的人之一。
She's so responsive and organized, and we truly appreciate her support. Thank you, Katie. If you enjoy Hidden Brain and want more of the show, you can now find our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus, across podcast platforms and devices. Hidden Brain Plus is where you'll find exclusive episodes of the show, including our segment Your Questions Answered, where we pass the mic to listeners to post their follow-ups
她反应迅速且组织有序，我们真心感谢她的支持。谢谢你，凯蒂。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》并想收听更多节目，你现在可以在各大播客平台和设备上找到我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》中，你可以找到节目的独家剧集，包括我们的板块“回答你的问题”，我们将麦克风交给听众，让他们提出后续问题
to some of our most popular guests. You can find Hidden Brain Plus on Apple podcasts or by going to apple.co. slash hidden brain. You can also find us via our Patreon page, especially if you're using an Android device, by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. At either site, support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.co. slash hidden brain, you can sign up for a free seven-day trial of Hidden Brain Plus. Your support helps us to bring you many more episodes of the show. We truly appreciate having you in our corner.
针对我们一些最受欢迎的嘉宾。你可以在Apple Podcasts上找到《隐藏的大脑 Plus》，或者访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。你也可以通过我们的Patreon页面找到我们，特别是如果你使用的是安卓设备，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。在上述任一网站，support.hiddenbrain.org或apple.co/hiddenbrain，你都可以注册《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的七天免费试用。你的支持帮助我们为你带来更多节目。我们真心感谢有你的支持。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡拉·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。